we know we can rely on you for being a
great guy to what an incredible friend
you were to meghan markle is have you
guys hung it out hung out at all since
then no we haven't spoken she just wrote
me a very nice thank you letter and i
framed it and that was very nice of her
to do she just appreciated that i was
honest and but it's so funny that we
live in a time where everyone's like
it's such a big deal i just did the
right thing
you know it's okay to feel like that
should be the norm and the status quo
but it's like whoa it's so crazy he told
the truth i think we should all be a
little more honest well thank you for
doing the right thing especially in
hollywood what a night did you watch the
whole show i was watching it on my phone
in a car down the street i'm still in
shock about you know what and it's okay
i don't know if it's real or fake but
either way that was entertaining we saw
the uncensored i think it was real did
you watch will apologize yeah but but he
didn't apologize to chris so i'm not
sure it's okay if they get into scruffle
later i'm gonna break it up what was the
right thing if the slap was real how do
you think it should have been handled
after that uh well i i feel that i want
to see them kiss and make up because are
they friends i don't even know i thought
they were like i don't that the whole
thing was crazy but i don't know what
the pro this has never happened before
so i don't know what to think right i'm
still just reeling so let me process it
on i'm going to get back to you on how
i'm going to resolve this situation you
could this is your new role
um well what is next for you what roles
are you most excited about coming up oh
so i just shot a movie uh with sydney
sweeney and paul hauser and eric dane a
couple of the cast members from euphoria
called national anthem kind of a cowboys
and indians new new modern take and then
i got a movie with lucas gage and zach
quinto called down low comedy so uh yeah
it works great you know after red rocket
i've been getting a lot of offers and
i'm just happy to be working at vanity
fair's oscars party tonight how does
that feel this is the hardest one to get
into and i got a plus one and i lost him
he's somewhere i'll find him megan and
harry uh they have been seen out in
about a little bit in hollywood what if
they're here tonight will you be happy
to see them i will go up and say hello
and hopefully we uh you know hopefully
in real life she's just as appreciative
as she was in the letter because it was
a very heartfelt letter i was tickled
[Music]
you